you were talking to a lot of people uh
who were referencing the movie Idiocracy
the Mike Judge film uh which has a very
famous introduction uh and I've also
pulled that clip which I want to roll
and talk about a little bit uh best
could you play the idiocracy
clip Evolution does not necessarily
reward intelligence with no natural
predators to thin the herd it began to
Simply reward those who reproduced the
most and left the intelligent to become
an endangered
species having kids is such an important
decision we're just waiting for the
right time it's not something you want
to rush into obviously no
way oh [__] I'm pregnant again [__] I
got too many damn kids thought you was
on the pill or some [__] hell no [__]
must have been thinking of Britney
Britney no
you there's no way we could have a child
now mm-m not with the market the way it
is no God no that just wouldn't make any
sense come on out [__] he don't care
about you yeah but there must be
something he likes over here mean
nothing to me
baby oh [__] it wasn't me it wasn't
me well we finally decided to have
children and I'm not pointing fingers
but it's not going
well and this is helping I'm just saying
that before I have't beat TR maybe you
should be willing to it's always me
right
well it's not my sperm
count so implications are obvious having
a lot of kids is for stupid people um
why do you think Endeavor right like
that's
the exactly why why do you think that it
has such cultural resonance what does
that say about attitudes towards kids
and
family U and I I love it because I first
heard about that uh movie The First Time
anyone ever asked me have you watched
watch idiocracy I was at a a reason
happy hour and said to one of my friends
there that I was expecting my second in
2008 and she said oh have you seen
Idiocracy and I think she meant it in a
h a friendly uh joking way but uh then
when she explained the plot I wasn't
sure how to take it um and yeah and this
is something I encountered in a a
playground in New Milford Conneticut
which I highlight as a a shrinking town
the playground was outside of elementary
school that's closed down and was
currently hosting senior yoga instead as
sort of the the the future and I think
again the idea that it's smart and both
sides get mocked in this movie right
like the the yepy couple with the 140
IQs are not coming out as as the you
know The Prudent the the people to look
up to but right really the idea that
raising kids is this because it's become
such a choice because it's not just kind
kind of something you do now there are
subcultures where finish school get a
job get married have kids is just kind
of what you're expected to do and well
if you're going to deviate from that
you're making a different Choice that's
fine but now it's not even that it's not
expected it's it's like choosing what
color sweater you're going to put on in
the morning it's it's an explicit Choice
it's a a lifestyle choice because of
that a the it leads to a culture that
says it's your problem if you have kids
but B it makes you feel and I quote
Stephanie Murray who's a great parenting
writer on this it it once it becomes a
choice then you have to do it all
exactly right it's like you I would tell
my kid don't go to college if you're not
going to try to get good grades and that
kind of thing and this is what people
say if you're not going to absolutely do
it right make sure you have everything
in order make sure you have the house in
the right school district and you have
the savings to send them to college and
you have lined up the piano teacher Etc
then don't do it and so that's again the
way in which I think it's a
self-reinforcing thing as people have
fewer children their perception of the
amount of inputs you need to do into
child rearing goes up which then makes
parenting seem more daunting which
causes people to put it off and
sometimes you put it off too long and
it's no longer in the cards for you to
me the opposite vision of this is um The
Sound of Music right like there's a
little bit of horseshoe Theory at play
where it's like okay the poor and low
class family and idiocracy okay they
have a ton of kids but then there's also
we see this actually um in a lot of the
data surrounding this sometimes it's the
ultra wealthy families like you know
Christopher Palmer's family and Sound of
Music who end up having a whole bunch of
kids and then they essentially live the
libertarian dream right like they have a
governance they do micros schooling like
it's it's an awesome sort of like means
of you know you can really scale up the
family but so do we need cultural
messages like that where we also show
this being like a very high class thing
or do we need cultural messages where
it's just seen as like Ultra attainable
to you what's the what's the IDE unal
manners yeah we need Maria to come and
raise all of the children for all of the
families I don't think perfectly behaved
kid the image of perfectly behaved kids
is the the right one um to give a an
example I try to get my kids to hold
especially my sons to hold open doors
for people because that's really easy to
teach them and it's really easy to just
say one word as you walk by them door
and then they'll hold the door open and
that makes other people happy and it's
really my kids can't sing in unison
again I have a son who can play the
guitar and that's the extent of the
music and I actually go we little
outfits made out of curtains you don't
have anybody making them outfits out of
drapes or anything what's the point of
having I criticize the mom fluenc in my
book The you know the Instagram moms who
everything is perfect and specifically
the ones who they all live in farmhouses
is a bizarre thing that I can't
understand and the reason it's I you I
can understand because it's supposed to
look oh well we are going a simple route
I mean that Farmhouse they made with the
first five million they made off of
their influencer cash um they often
started with cash and the simple rote
like you notice that denim is all like
made to point perfectly towards the Hues
of the ballerina mother's blue eyes
right like it's none of it is simple
it's all extremely curated none of that
helps people have kids because that's
what causes people say oh I have to have
my life that much in order to raise kids
to have kids who are basically Happy who
you know and they eat nuggets and french
fries for dinner at least once a week
that's the kind of attainable image of
the parent I actually praise in family
unfriendly I praise the lawn that's
scattered with like footballs and
tricycles and there's some dead grass
from where the you know the home plate
was left or the skateboard was left
upside down to be a little bit messy and
happy and that sort of thing and not not
perfect kids not IV League kids so I you
know have lower Ambitions for your kids
is one of the messages I have in the
first two chapters for the book so maybe
it's not idiocracy or Sound of Music
maybe it's like Cheaper by the Dozen
remember like that movie I guess there
was the original one and then the Steve
Martin remake right even Cheaper by the
Dozen um because he's like militaristic
that did set for me a tone and I admit
in the book I say when I'm a bad dad
when I lose my temper it's because I
want to think of myself as militaristic
like if I Whistle my dogs c a certain
whistle and Cheaper by the Dozen he has
a certain whistle where his 12 kids come
and again there's a couple things I'm
I'm good at which is my kids open the
door and they behave well in Mass but
after that I I try to be you know
relatively Laz fair with uh with the
kids don't always succeed at that but
yeah that that that that model that the
things you think you need to do for your
kids you don't they might look like a
mess sometimes your house will look like
a mess sometimes your kids won't get
into Harvard but that those things are
all fine that's the main message that I
think needs to get conveyed to people
now now does that sound to you like I'm
saying you should live you know be a
dude having babies with all his
neighbors in the trailer park well those
sound the same to you I'm sorry I don't
have much to say but I think you can see
sort of a stable couple with a a
moderate income and just trying to raise
happy kids that that definitely is
doable even in this world you do have to
change your expectations hey thanks for
watching that clip from our new show
just asking questions you can watch
another clip here
or the full episode here new episodes
drop every week so subscribe to reent
TV's YouTube channel to get notified
when that happens or to the just asking
questions podcast on Apple Spotify or
any other podcatcher see you next week